So one of the areas where this kind of ordering process takes place in social network analysis
is in measuring the centrality of different nodes.
We talked a little bit about centrality in the previous unit,
but let me talk a little bit about some different types of centrality that you might find useful.
One that we're going to return to,
and we've already kind of touch on is this node of closeness centrality.
The idea that a given node is central if it has short path to other nodes in the network.
Between this centrality has to do with the idea that a node is central
if most of the shortest path between arbitrarily chosen pairs of nodes in the network
end up having to pass through the node in question.
It's between most to the other nodes. It's kind of stuck between them.
Node centrality is actually a much simpler concept,
which says that the node is central if it has lots of edges
If it's very well connected, and this is well connected in a very local sense
just in terms of the degree of the node or the number of neighbors that it has.
Let's look at this one first and then we're going to combine
what we learned with other kinds of path base metrics next.